okay [ __ ] at your boy psychobabble um
this is a tricky one its mission 6 it
sing fatal any plans now let me break it
down for y'all [ __ ] some products
might not be able to stay in storage for
long figure I had a cell manager stop
create 200 bread and less then 50 wait
I'll got good good okay good so let's do
this let me just get a nice comfy
picture okay like what we got lots of
fire money all right we always need tree
three [ __ ] oxygen um you need some
water towers okay okay but now we also
need some money so let's do this um
small apartment I just like to quickly
set up a town it's actually pretty large
apartment I set up some [ __ ] youth
right now I don't need at youth so I'm
good is that was it neat okay
grass how they [ __ ] get to each spot
can I work let me just see if they can
okay they can use grass okay um [ __ ]
what I need electricity is doing a link
so get a new one of these guys come on
[ __ ] a little more
how's that not making any more lectures
today is it just like making very little
to knock it these are nice because you
want only not money thing okay um I need
fish but where's the wheat ok how do you
fine ok cafe Brad oh I got make bread
without wheat all right [ __ ] ok bread
oh my me that all right ouch it's
backwards I don't see how that's here
this is neat neat sweet [ __ ] do i
generate wait okay so I basically have
to keep the wheat at a good level like I
spent like zero because it has to curate
but not make too much ok there we get
perfect perfect ok [ __ ] it will honor
thank God that you were some fine space
inside the [ __ ] the veggies veggies
yeah they're a JS beer garden okay um
planters I'm gonna make fertilizer
against [ __ ] organic waste okay
leave my [ __ ] liar yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay so we're gonna have to make
another level over here Shen kind of
rotate this I'm gonna hop this [ __ ] up
okay [ __ ] okay give me that labor
force I'll of labor and I'll of force
it's crazy okay I don't need money again
my shiny on the market consumer labor
and bread huh it's a lot of money no
bread is still going up down um just
teach me to a consumer labor anymore I
can a slave ours is a dictatorship [ __ ]
they like what the [ __ ] wait how the
[ __ ] can I got now
yeah sorry for giving you guys grass did
okay still not enough labor [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is going on here that is
decaying
hmm what does it not have these are no
labor waiting is plenty of Labor [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] what does it not have it has
water it has wheat it's a neat people so
what a [ __ ] knees okay this is
getting a disaster is turning it to a
[ __ ] disaster okay try this again
chalice again Backes w fields let's see
what's [ __ ] the king now no it's not
so [ __ ] yo [ __ ] it is ok good good good
don't [ __ ] are these guys mechanic
[ __ ] fertilizer what the [ __ ] makes
fertilizer
oh [ __ ] this is how it gets hard okay
what is that how we did okay um okay
we're back on track or back hun sure
what the [ __ ] is that was it a school
she'll get no fresh air either
so the harder missions I can't be a
shortage of Labor
um these are so good at labor hey just
do this okay now we need some more
[ __ ] water okay oh [ __ ] here these
guys complaining about were they not
getting
oh they're choked off by you guys around
them good news grass stat hmm ok I can
do more wait there I didn't take me
chuck out so easily Jesus oh so down
arrows makes just like choking something
else ok i'm starting to get this game an
hour again too much [ __ ] weed some me
another bakery where are you baking
right there
[ __ ] ok ok no where is no heirs I we got
this yeah what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened a hat what is this guy need it
oh [ __ ] here's water labor and
fertilizer
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] what's it not
getting
what is this guy not getting
I don't understand what suite is [ __ ]
dying
Oh a second a [ __ ] weed
okay here's the plan just gonna go
[ __ ] a whole lot of grass to connect
everything
hmm
I can I [ __ ] delete things sometimes
okay access data decay data that one's
good said like not getting enough water
now it is [ __ ] it's not
okay so are we had a golden level now
what is sleeting a bread not this lady
ok
just a little surplus of weight come on
just give me some of that weight baybay
give me some of that oil hey stick I
should be good now right
oh ok you need eat if you're like
skimping it doesn't work lock ok ok
that's gonna get healed pretty soon
intently already's [ __ ] things
how's this guy doing [ __ ] i don't want
of wheat i think i can make weight down
here
the [ __ ] is going on here now
I can't let me close all this [ __ ]
kick it
yeah sucking a risqué trying to make
some bread down just trying to make some
brat
what if I have to make this X smart ok
so we right there may be a little too
much week but if I can see I think they
should do it I think this is a good
combination
what was the mission again shet tutorial
lesson 50 wheat [ __ ] okay it's a thing
out of them
hmm what if I put this week here and
then just [ __ ] made another bakery
and then when the time comes second like
that just like that
okay come on Brad come on come on God
higher one party [ __ ] i just got to keep
juggling it so basically i could just
add a weight thing here if it's getting
too low and then it's getting too hot
equals the 50 I just I mean you can't
change them so we need more weeks but a
week there it's going too high yeah I
had one guy saves going to zero I could
just like it's getting too low just
[ __ ] delete this and let's get to
hide elitepad it's it's it's crazy I
know I know really nice of this got to
[ __ ] all right level 200 shortly this
drops too low [ __ ] put this here so
even if we see this is with me to like
strips so now you know there you go
there you go
shuts come alone better personally and
Amy yeah and better look in the latest
batch 193 Alma's their God